or cet énorme nuage de fumée au dessus
de flogny la chapelle près de tonnerre
cet après midi c'est l'ancienne
fromagerie paul renard qui a pris feu un
important dispositif de sécurité a été
déployé les 5000 m de bâtiment était
désaffecté et un périmètre de sécurité a
été installé en raison de risques de
toxicité des fumées qui se dégagent
l'incendié pour leur maîtrise et je vous
propose d'écouter les précisions du
maire de la commune
on a entendu des craquements en début
d'après midi où l'otan autour de 15h et
puis s'en est suivie une fumée très
importante très intense
donc on s'est rendu sur place tout de
suite et on a vu que voilà les bâtiments
étaient en feu et la fumée est d'autant
plus importante que c'est des hangars
frigorifique
alors c'est que des matériaux isolants
et quand ça prend face à des gars je
pense en plus d'aider la pollution à mon
avis et si fumer sont elles sur le goût
de toxiques
à mon avis tout ce qui est matière
isolante c'est du produit chimique donc
il ya des grandes chances